grazie grazie grazie dell'unità perché
invenzione della memoria
questo questa frase che può sembrare
quasi una contraddizione in termini o un
ossimoro queste due parole un po
contraddittorie
se vogliamo la prima invenzione un
qualcosa che ha che fare più con con
fluidità con rapidità un elemento quasi
improvviso della creatività della mente
e la memoria a che fare più con con la
stratificazione un processo estremamente
più lento
questa frase che ho preso da un grande
architetto italiano del novecento
ernesto nathan rogers primo che ho
voluto riprendere dal punto da un grande
architetto italiano del novecento
mi serve per portare oggi alla vostra
attenzione quello che è stato negli anni
del mio fare l'architetto quindi di fare
architettura un approccio un approccio
al progetto che ha sempre cercato di
portare dentro appunto la materia viva
del progetto degli elementi che potremmo
definire quasi all'interno della cucina
progettuale che hanno a che fare con la
storia con la memoria un senso più ampio
il territorio e il paesaggio in quanto
però elementi creativi dentro il
progetto non elementi chiaramente
statici che fini a se stessi potremmo
sintetizzare questo con la
contemporaneità ha bisogno appunto di
memoria di storia di territorio di
paesaggio
credo che questi elementi che invadono
che sono insiti nel dell'ambiente che ci
circondano debbano essere utilizzati
gente come una materia compositiva
dentro il progetto in grado di inventare
e riattualizzare questa memoria di farne
un elemento vivo quindi non statico non
musealizzato renderlo pienamente dentro
logge e pienamente dentro la
contemporaneità rappresentare quindi
l'uomo e la comunità oggi e questo al
quale deve tendere l'architettura e la
modifica del territorio in particolare
nella specificità del territorio
italiano che chiaramente a una serie di
valenze di caratteristiche che lo
contraddistinguono
rispetto ad altre zone del mondo e ancor
più in particolare nel territorio
toscano
direi in particolare ancora di più nel
territorio aretino ci stiamo ad arezzo
quindi parliamo di questo fantastico
ambiente che che abbiamo intorno
questo tema è ancora più urgente è
presente infatti dobbiamo come dire in
inizio prima di mostrarvi anche una
serie di progetti fatti in questi anni
aver ben chiaro un elemento che il
territorio il paesaggio sono pienamente
un'opera antropica questa immagine quasi
da cartolina che che vediamo per come
conosciamo questo territorio questo è
frutto del lavoro della fantasia della
creatività e dell'ingegno dell'uomo in
situazioni socio economiche culturali
estremamente diverse ma che nel tempo ha
protratto questa necessità di adattare
di costruire di modificare il proprio
ambiente
vediamo qui appunto alcune immagini
quasi ormai forse stereotipate ma poi
dirci danno conto di questo incessante e
continuo elemento di modifica bonifica
della valdichiana lo schema dei dei
campi delle linee
l'edilizia stessa delle colline come
elemento a tavolino messo in un in un
territorio recuperato il carattere anche
dell'architettura
la cartolina di arezzo ma che anche essa
stessa un paesaggio urbano ma sempre
paesaggio un'opera continua tra appunto
esterno campagna territorio più naturale
e parte organizzata quindi tutto questo
è un'opera artificiale e naturalmente
tutto questo non è non è natura
tutto questo enorme bagaglio di
conoscenza e di elementi trasposto nel
oggi che cosa ci deve raccontare a mio
modo di vedere che la persona e l'uomo
sono la misura del progetto in una
duplice accezione potremmo dire di
componente sia spaziale che è l'elemento
poi cardine del fare architettura ed un
elemento simbolico al quale l'uomo può
dire sempre ambito quando questi due
elementi riescono a coincidere un'opera
architettonica abbiamo degli elementi
risultati estremamente significativi
potremmo definire anche questo approccio
umanistico questo dialogo incessante con
la storia che è un lavoro complesso e
difficile che pone il paesaggio e la
memoria nel progetto architettonico è
come dire avuto un processo ininterrotto
anche fino a dire ai giorni più recenti
anche come dire nel novecento possiamo
trovare grandi esponenti e grandi opere
che come the tramandano questa questo
approccio è oggi rapidissimamente alcuni
spot in un elenco sicuramente incompleto
libera a capri casa malaparte centro
residenziale oliveti a ivrea di gabetti
e isola che sicuramente
gli ospiti che parleranno dopo di me
conoscono bene ma anche il michelucci
della chiesa sulla vostra da questa
straordinaria metafora del viaggio lungo
questo asse fondamentale per l'italia la
tenitura che si fa narrazione anche di
certi temi
il gruppo toscano con mille luci
gamberini forse quello che è il primo
esempio di architettura contemporanea
italiana che la stazione di santa maria
novella che dialoga a dire a pari
livello con la cattedrale stessa qui
vediamo lo straordinario paesaggio
corridoio interno leonardo savioli
questa villa che pochi conoscono e a 5
chilometri da qui nel territorio aretino
una casa che ha oltre 50 anni ma che
ancora attesta la propria
contemporaneità e la propria attenzione
al paesaggio e all'ambiente
assolutamente diversa da quello che è un
approccio storicistico e così via che
leonardo nicea monterinaldi questa è la
casa studio dell'architetto dove
artificio e natura diventano un unicum
questi esempi che non hanno fatto come
dire la scuola sui grandi numeri non
hanno avuto come dire il seguito che
meritavano hanno sempre avuto una grande
attenzione al luogo nel quale si
insediavano e un'attenzione in modo
particolare al paesaggio alla memoria
del territorio stesso
ma soprattutto un elemento cardine è
quello dell'uso della storia senza
falsificazione questo è il tema centrale
che ritroverete in tutto quello che oggi
vi farò vedere quindi da tutto questo
oggi non possiamo che ragionare quando
abbiamo a che fare con il progetto
architettonico e la modifica del
territorio in senso più generale che in
una scala paesaggistica territoriale non
è più pensabile ragionare per singoli
edifici per singoli episodi per tutte le
motivazioni che
io ho anticipato su questi presupposti
quindi in questi anni insieme agli amici
e colleghi dello store studio mi sono
sempre mosso appunto nella mia pratica
professionale con una particolare
attenzione quindi alla dimensione
paesaggistica dell'architettura e al suo
dato simbolico
oggi vi mostrerò molto rapidamente con
appunto i tempi del ted alcuni progetti
di tipologie scala molto diversi ma per
dargli significato di tutto quello che
vi ho detto fino adesso
il primo è un piccolo edificio una
cappella ospedaliera noi siamo a belluno
siamo ai piedi delle dolomiti
l'obiettivo era è grande ospedale un
fuori scala territoriale con le dolomiti
alle spalle
l'obiettivo era quello di creare un
luogo che consentisse il raccoglimento
un isolarsi dall'esterno ma anche un
luogo di ricerca di speranza perché la
cappella ospedaliera un luogo dove si
accede con problemi chiaramente quanto
meno fisici o psicologici necessità ma
anche un luogo di culto di religiosità
aperto a persone le più diverse sia di
appunto di credo religioso di
nazionalità e di censo che cosa abbiamo
voluto trovare qui lavorare su alcuni
elementi quasi archetipi di necessità
dell'uomo di mettersi in contatto con la
trascendenza
ma anche di rinnovare appunto la propria
intimità con un uso particolare della
luce che è l'elemento un po che
determina determina questo spazio
infatti se ritorniamo nell'immagine
questa è una sezione prospettica dove
questa stanza diventa quasi una grotta
nel quale isolarsi rifugiarsi tra tutto
il contesto intorno e dove l'unico
elemento appunto e la luce radente da
dietro il piccolo altare ridotta ai
minimi termini che consentano
questo questo raccoglimento questo
ritrovarsi con se stessi secondo
progetto invece che vi voglio mostrare
chiaramente un ambito completamente
diverso a montevarchi sempre in
provincia di arezzo una piazza quindi
uno spazio urbano di relazione una zona
margine di quasi di cerniera tra la
città medioevale la sua cinta muraria e
il cassero appunto medievale e la zona
di ampliamento otto novecentesca con le
gli assi importanti soprattutto quello
quello verso firenze questo appunto e il
castro che domina la piazza che cosa
abbiamo voluto trovare riproporre
ricreare un po un un elemento che era
latente sulla piazza e che era appunto
la vecchia cinta muraria che era stata
battuta tra fine ottocento e primi
novecento e che noi abbiamo voluto
riproporre nuovamente come un elemento
invece che unisce non divide
questo modello un ulteriore esempio di
come la storia può essere un elemento
creativo nel nostro progetto diventa uno
strappo sulla pavimentazione dove acqua
e pietra si uniscono una modellazione
del suolo attraverso appunto un piano
continuo questa è una particolare della
fontana dove abbiamo messo un opera di
ernesto galeffi che al famosissimo
artista che abitava a pochi a pochi
metri da qui li e quindi questo questo
elemento diventa un punto di giunzione
non di divisione tra sparsi di relazioni
diversi e nelle ore notturne va a ed
evidenziare molto significativamente il
cassero che è l'elemento comunque
predominante della piazza ecco il terzo
progetto invece un edificio quindi una
situazione estremamente più complessa un
concorso internazionale di idee nuova
sede della provincia di arezzo
il progetto di qualche anno fa quando
ancora le province andavano di moda
un progetto che aveva l'obiettivo
ottenere 22 risultati il primo di
rappresentare il senso dell'istituzione
senso dell'istituzione provincia quindi
un qualcosa che rappresenta un
territorio ma anche un edificio che
fosse metafora del territorio stesso
la provincia di arezzo ha un territorio
estremamente interessante e articolato e
diversificato ho tanti elementi
estremamente interessanti l'uso delle
murature a secco sia nella conduzione
dei terreni agricoli ma anche nelle
costruzioni quelle più spontanee il
fenomeno geologico delle basi o qualcosa
che nasce per erosione che si modifica
continuamente che non è mai uguale a se
stesso usato punto che vi dicevo del
muro a secco per gli oliveti terrazzati
in una spina dorsale che da cortona
regnano troverete su questo territorio
alcuni elementi quasi archetipi che
vengono appunto dal periodo del rusco
roma una serie di elementi che
caratterizzano fortemente e che amò leon
a mio modo di vedere perna ne ho anche
la memoria collettiva di queste di
questo territorio nella planimetria
generale ritroviamo questi elementi
completamente ri e interpretati fatti
l'edificio diventa un territorio
trattato come un terreno scavato quasi
come e balze che vi dicevo prima dove
non c'è soluzione di continuità tra gli
edifici e le sistemazioni a verde
parcheggi appunto dove diventa appunto
una metafora del territorio stesso un un
edificio che diventa muro che diventa
collina che si apre a se stesso quindi
che accoglie i propri cittadini che non
lavora sul tema dell'istituzione come
elemento retorico e astratto e la fronte
urbano invece che lavora sul tema del
muro come home come se fosse un
terrapieno e senza distinzione tra pieni
e vuoti un po riprendendo quelle quelle
immagini che avevamo visto prima su
duratura così presente in questo in
questo territorio
l'ultimo progetto che vi faccio vedere
oggi invece è l'ultimo veramente in
senso cronologico è il progetto che
attualmente abbiamo abbiamo sul tavolo è
una casa unifamiliare quindi un tema se
vogliamo più più semplice tra virgolette
vi siamo a terranuova sempre nel
valdarno aretino un lotto con una
particolare un particolare dislivello
tra la strada appunto e la posa
dell'edificio e abbiamo voluto riprovare
a lavorare sempre sul tema del muro del
muro di contenimento ma anche muratura
che in questo caso va a qualche modo
organizzare lo spazio interno esterno
soprattutto tra appunto la sistemazione
esterna non questa piscina che si adagia
sul terreno qui vediamo appunto il muro
trattato anche con dire con sottrazione
di elementi per esaltare alcune
prospettive che da questo lotto si si
percepiscono e questa continuità anche
materica tra l'esterno e l'interno dove
il materiale diventa elemento
caratterizzante del progetto e dove
abbiamo disposto una lastra metallica
che diventa copertura e che evidenza
soprattutto le parti le parti rimaste
aperte di grande luce del grande spazio
che cosa che cosa ho voluto mostrarvi
con con questi progetti nella rapidità
di questo incontro
sostanzialmente di come contemporaneità
progetto contemporaneo e memoria di un
luogo possono essere estremamente questo
confronto sia estremamente prolifico ed
interessante
l'architettura contemporanea deve trarre
ispirazione da un luogo ce l'hanno
insegnato all'università al famoso
genius loci
lo voglio dire ampliare alla dimensione
appunto del paesaggio
della memoria complessiva che un luogo
contiene sia che sia una memoria di tipo
culturale legata ai materiali
estremamente importanti agli elementi
simbolico spirituali delle quasi e
all'elemento spaziale che ripeto è la
materia viva del fare del fare
architettura in qualche modo
l'architetto va come un alchimista a
distillare da tutti questi elementi un
elemento nuovo è quello appunto che mi
riporta all'inizio del termine
invenzione tutto questo senza una
nostalgia mendy verso il passato senza
un sentirsi inferiori senza una
falsificazione della storia con
l'elemento fondamentale che è quello di
avere una grande fiducia e che
l'elemento che vorrei che fosse espanso
a tutti a tutti i cittadini a tutti voi
di grande fiducia nelle potenzialità
dell'architettura che a mio modo di
vedere è in grado di rappresentare
l'oggi e quindi anche di per figurare il
domani vorrei concludere questo mio
intervento con con una metafora quasi
un'esperienza l'esperienza personale
qualche anno fa entrando in un in un
bistrot di parigi mi sono imbattuto in
un cartello all'ingresso come capita
sempre invece di trovare i prezzi delle
pietanze c'era un appunto una frase che
diceva questo la gastronomia e l'arte di
trasformare i nutrimento in buon umore
questa frase oltre che per la chiarezza
e la nitidezza del messaggio mi fece
scattare un
l'esigenza di trasporla in architettura
nutrimento e il riparo sono le due
necessità primarie del l'uomo e ne ho
fatto una traduzione in questo senso
l'architettura e l'arte di trasformare
la necessità di ripararsi quindi il
riparo in benessere benessere in
un'accezione estremamente ampia quindi
benessere fisico legato alle prestazioni
anche dell'edificio agli aspetti
tecnologici che naturalmente poi ci sono
fondamentali ma anche psicologico quindi
il rapporto simbolico legato alla
memoria
l'elemento sociale l'architettura in
grado di determinare anche i rapporti
relazionali all'interno dello spazio che
tutto tiene e che ripeto è l'elemento
poi carne del fare architettura
questo è quanto secondo me la rilettura
dovrebbe cercare di tenere ed è quanto
con il mio lavoro cerco di perseguire
quotidianamente grazie